[Music]
the screen show with how Rudnick guys
it's the end of the year and you know
what that means it's time for the screen
our annual awards show that you've come
to know and love join us as we celebrate
the best and worse in the very specific
categories that we made up moments
before we turned on the camera
Malone sequel goes to Skyfall come on
did you see the way they break that
house at the end I was waiting for Joe
Pesci and Daniel Stern to bust in there
next is the Christopher Nolan award that
goes to the trailer with the most
exciting use of this sound effect yeah
that one the nominees are
World War Z the Avengers star trek into
darkness Pacific Rim
Prometheus wrath of the Titans GI Joe
retaliation and the winner is no one
seriously guys find a new thing up next
is the Anna Kendrick award the Anna
Kendrick award goes to the girl who like
you kind of don't really notice at first
but then it sneaks up on you and you're
like I totally do her the Anna Kendrick
award goes to Anna Kendrick and
pitch-perfect Congrats Anna I
surprisingly really want to bone you our
next award is one you've all been
waiting for
we now present the nominees for the best
TV booths Brody's wife from homeland all
the women from Game of Thrones and
Alison Pill from news room whose Twitpic
was an accidental topic and the winner
is Lena Dunham from girls because she's
smart funny and slightly attainable for
me hi next we have the worst thing Ghost
Rider award and the nominees are here
comes the boom the watch that's my boy
and the winner is Ghost Rider - spirit
of Vengeance congratulations guys for
taking this franchise further into the
crapper and the award for movie they
have grandmother masturbated to goes to
three-way tie between Hope Springs Best
Exotic Marigold Hotel and Magic Mike the
false advertising award goes to the grey
who in the trailer promised us Liam
Neeson putting glass bottles on his
hands so he can fight a wolf and really
didn't deliver it just cut to black what
the [ __ ] I want to see some wolf on
Neeson action don't just cut to black
what a cop
now that all the awards are handed out
it's time for the in memoriam segment
[Music]
your movie sucks so bad
you sound real bad
you watched it happen it's your phone
we all want
your movie slap so bad
they were dumb
you sound real bad
dum-dum don't squirt
[Music]
it's your phone
we all
what a year it was hey thanks for
watching everybody happy new year
watch us next year aka next week I'm Hal
Rudnick my bike would each of you please
watch me
yes yes are you serious
would you ask me oh yeah great put it up
on my new year hey we've done we did
this exact same thing with Wolf Blitzer
it's